welcome to this video yep this is the
first video for 2015
so
to all of you happy new year and
all the best
for 2015 for you and your families
let's see what i can do in this game
this is not played on
in 2015 i have to admit this is
pre-recorded
on new year's eve yeah so it's not that
that far off
but um
let's see what's going on here sin brain
i never played that guy
many times won many tournaments okay
it's an older account
yeah we can transpose to the dragon how
did i get there actually
okay
yeah this is also move many uh possible
moves
in this um in this line a5 queen a5 okay
i'm playing a
kind of a solid setup here with
capturing d6 bishop d7 to c6
this is nothing great but black is
fairly solid
let's see what this guy is doing it's
not very high rated for gm
some are simply not that great at blitz
or they don't play often
this kind of quick time controls
yeah should i go 97 yeah probably
the threat e5 is already a bit of an
annoyance
so let's straight trade this off
and see
okay
well well well um if i play e5 yeah
you're going to a7 you're serious about
that yeah
this thing has absolutely no squares
besides a7 he's really doing that
funny
b6 looks like a trap of the bishop and
then rook d6 yeah
remarkable
if i start with queen c7 threatening b6
is there any way for him 95 yeah it
takes
bishop takes
amazing
okay
so that's not going to work okay b6 rook
d6
problem is that
my c6 bishop is hanging
still a queen c7
now
i don't see it
i don't see it i think i'm just winning
this this thing
yeah
you can do that but at the end i will
still i will still win this bishop right
if not something really unfair is going
on
i mean
i should really win now after you played
this this stuff
okay i have to take here bishop d5
and now what he has knight b5 yeah
you're really serious
huh
might be five
queen c5
he will take queen c7
knight
it's not really clear
now i have to have to do that and then
probably take on c2 and then he has rook
c1 yeah no i can still take a four hangs
that's totally weird he completely
blundered into bishop a7 and if that's
not directly losing this is sheer luck
really funny
yeah okay so
what about this now he's not taking on
a8 because knight b5 might be
might be feasible at first i can take c2
it's really the way to go yeah the other
other squares for the queen look totally
bad
yeah
a4 hangs rook c1 i can take a form
i have no idea here what's going on i've
spent tons of time
yeah he can take eight he can play i
mean even rook c1 is it's not clear
that move okay
which means i will be in exchange up
okay so i can go here first and he's got
of course he's got the a pawn and that
that's that's clear
yeah not much not much to do
i have to do that and then take b2
for some reason he's not taking on a5 i
don't know why
maybe he wants to play bishop f7 but
that's just bad okay
this is the idea knight to f7
i can play queen b6 for queen trade
okay let's do that
you can take off on
that's not a quick trade
okay
okay then let's do that
i'm expecting absolutely no movie in
this game it's really playing
completely
contrary to what i'm thinking
check
um
time warning yeah let's do this
59 seconds
yeah
59 seconds
my position isn't clear really
queen f6 i'm not sure if this was right
but
i needed to to play
check
and i think this is just a trade and at
the end his knight is in a problem
i mean where is this piece going it has
no squares
yeah rook d8 bishop d8 the knight is
trapped
and i'm threatening rook takes b5 with
the winning end game
and on a rook move i take on yeah yeah
so i'm winning now i think
yeah the knight has no square it's kind
of a funny
funny night trap
white resides yeah kind of a weird game
he really he didn't see that at all e5
and
with bishop a7
i cannot believe it yeah i cannot really
but maybe it is it is okay i don't know
the comp is not seeing
anything much here
it wants to play queen c7
tier
queen c7 i discarded because of that but
yeah but here
yeah it's true it's true what i didn't
really
see here was that i can just go here
yeah like this and then i'm threatening
b6
and the bishop still has no way out this
is just such a ridiculous placement of
this piece
you cannot get this out i mean this this
is something along these is probably
relatively best and here black just wins
yeah with two pieces for the rook and a
good coordination
yeah i went here and now we can take and
this is actually good for white yeah
funny
rook takes d7 however is the move that
uh that stockfish is giving
yeah well this makes lots of sense right
just get the rid of the knight and then
take on b6 and white has got two pawns
two pawns for for the exchange and
really good pieces yeah there's
something coming to d5
like this and then then you will put
something on d5 with good play
and i have no tactical things yeah
the bishop is still a little bit i can
always go here now yeah
this was this was the problem and here i
mean things are really not clear at all
didn't didn't understand what was going
on i mean white is certainly okay
i can always um take a8 and and go from
there i'm not i'm not threatening to win
the a7 bishop now it's
it's a funny placement of this piece of
course and probably yeah
not optimal or anything but i don't see
how i really exploit it he went here
this is this uh surprised me
because i thought that yeah at least i'm
keeping the exchange but
yeah here queen a5 was was the only move
i thought but
he just went here
and this is this is probably a bad idea
why didn't i take here this is much
better
getting rid of this this dangerous
potentially dangerous a pawn
yeah after this
something like this is just good just
good for black
yeah i'm the exchanger so it's it's not
easy for him he can
get a pawn back but here i mean this is
all
all a liability
here i'm threatening actually difficult
rook takes c6 is a very big threat jam
like wins
and here i did it i mean
i don't know
i think this looks like decent defense
but i'm not sure
if he has some way to yeah coordinate
i mean for example if white would
somehow manage to get bishop to d5 and
get the a pawn even for traits then he
will not lose probably
but maybe he does not have this this
possibility ah here rook b6 watch was
much stronger i was a little bit
irritated by the time
disadvantage now this was strong very
strong
rook d1 and now here is quite nice now
i'm threatening this and what is exactly
his idea i'm also going for this
yeah like wins here directly
like -4
okay i went here which is not so good
and now he should trade and play bishop
back again and now the bishop back
somewhere like here
yeah and this you can continue to fight
i mean
black might win somehow but it's not
easy at all
i have this
you can go here maybe
b7
the knight is not not so great here
really
maybe i get e4 black is clearly better
but you can fight
so what what did you do actually i he
played that i'm sorry so i should have
played rook before yeah okay
this
yeah and now rook d8 wins yeah so i
didn't see that at the time i was just
seeing that i can go here
and only now i recognize that really
black is winning i'm threatening rook
takes c8 for two pieces
against the rook and then i'd have an
extra piece i'm an exchange up already
so
he he only has this basically what he
did and now this is really trapped he
cannot avoid it
this is this kind of thing going to here
here and then the a pawn is even even
promoting
yeah that was interesting bishop a7 was
was really a weird setup
okay i hope you enjoyed this game thanks
for watching